there's a great Chinese story as a
Chinese proverb it's told many ways but
here's the way I heard it a young man is
born with an unbelievable gift for horse
riding and everyone in the village says
you're so lucky and the monk says we'll
see and he falls off his horse and
breaks his leg ends his career and
everyone in the village says you're so
unlucky and the monk says we'll see and
then war breaks out and all the young
men are sent off to battle but he can't
go because of his busted leg and
everyone in the village says you're so
lucky and the monk says we'll see and
the point is good bad I don't know what
those things are we perceive things as
good or bad because of the lens we're
looking through and what I have learned
about my own life and my own career is
that every strength that I have has
liability and every weakness that I have
there is hidden opportunity right so for
example self-confidence really important
got to have self-confidence right the
liability of self-confidence is
sometimes you come across a little cocky
liability you have to manage that's
called humility we like humility because
what it means is I don't believe my own
press right that's what humility is I
have these strengths and I acknowledge
those strengths I understand I have to
manage them for fear that they will
actually become liabilities but the
opposite is also true
so I'm disorganized right I'm not
organized which huge liability you know
somebody says we got to do business with
you they give me their business card
I'll lose it
you know and it's bad and it and I beat
myself up for it and I'm like I'm
leaving money on the table like I'm
literally cause myself so much stress
because I'm just organs I've tried all
kinds of systems and they're good for
like a week and then I go back to my old
ways here's what happened early on my
career
I'd meet somebody they said we have to
do business with me they give me their
business card a week and a half later
two weeks later I found their business
card underneath something with a bunch
of dust bunnies I'm like God [ __ ] right
everybody else who's organized already
called them the next day already sent
them an email they're all over it I
called them up a week and a half later
and like turns out they want to do
business with me even more because they
thought I was busy
[Applause]
good bad I don't know now I'm not taking
pride in my disorganization I'm simply
saying and all of my weaknesses there
are hidden opportunities and what I'm
trying to do again I don't believe in
good bad right wrong I believe in
balance and what I'm trying to do is is
recognize that when I beat myself up
where is the lesson I've stopped trying
to think of things as right decisions
and wrong decisions and now I tried to
think of them as right decisions and
lessons learned and I will beat myself
up if I didn't learn the lesson I repeat
the mistake that I take that hurts me
but the biggest mistake I've made in my
life that caused me more pain that I had
to overcome was the false belief that I
have to know all the answers and what I
don't I have to pretend that I do for
some reason when we're in a position of
authority or rank or when you're the
front man you're the sales guy having
all the answers is what we think we have
to have and it turns out when we have an
answer for everything people actually
don't believe we have an answer for
anything because nobody has the answers
to everything and the biggest lesson I
learned in a professional context in a
meeting in a sales opportunity when
somebody's asked me a question for me to
say I don't know or let's find out
together or there are other people who
are better qualified to do that than me
I remember in early sales meetings when
I learned this lesson I used to be able
to great I used to be great at
everything cuz I had to be right I got
to portray confidence in his new
business and it got to the point where
it was so it was so hard to win business
then at some point I think I probably in
a moment of weakness quite frankly I was
probably exhausted that's usually how
one learns these lessons because you let
your guard down in a meeting somebody
said we want you to do this this and
that I'm looking at tons of money on the
table and I said I'm really good at that
I'll do that I'm okay at that that I
really strongly recommend you hire
somebody else because I suck at that
I'll work with them but I won't do it
the fact that I said that they wanted to
hire me to do everything even more
because they've never had anybody that
honest all the other sales guys who were
pitching their business for the same
thing told him they were great at
anything and
I was the only one who said so so so the
whole idea of saying I don't know even
to my own colleagues I need help
profoundly profoundly changed the course
of my life turns out we're constantly
surrounded by people who want to help us
including our own clients but they
didn't offer their help but they didn't
think we needed it because we said we
knew everything so for me that lesson
was one of the biggest mistakes that
I've made in my whole career and I think
you when you say was something that went
right was having the courage to ask for
help when I was in really really bad
shape when I was really down to simply
call a friend and say I'm struggling
[Music]
[Music]